Quoi, j'ai ... j'ai déjà fait une vidéo sur les jeux vidéos ?
Ah, c'est normal, c'est normal, c'est parce qu'en fait là c'est la suite.
J'ai juste fait une pause entre temps...
Une pause de presque 1 an, oui, oui, ça commence à faire une bonne pause là. C'est sûr
Alors, je suis désolé mais...
Il y a trop d’incohérences dans les jeux vidéos.
Même, même dans mes jeux vidéos préférés, par exemple, j'adore Zelda, voilà.
C'est un des mes jeux préférés,
j'adore jouer pendant 40 heures pour sauver la princesse et avoir un bisou sur la joue en échange,
c'est super!
Mais dans ce jeu, je vois que ça choque personne. Absolument personne :
Le système des pots placés dans les maisons.
C'est quoi ce jeu !?
Un autre jeu que j'adore le jeu vidéo auquel j'ai le plus joué quand j'étais gamin.
C'est Pokémon sur Gameboy. Voilà, c'est dit: Pikachu, Dracaufeu, Ratibox...
Mais, qui ? Qui a eu l'idée de mettre une seule sauvegarde dans le jeu ?
Une seule !!  UNE !!!!!
Alors, forcément, il t'arrive ça...
Ah, au fait Cyprien, tu en es où dans Pokémon ?
Bah, j'ai presque terminé le jeu en fait.
Attends, c'est pas ma Gameboy, ça ?
Si, si. Et t'as raison, il est trop bien ton jeu !
T'as pas sauvegardé j’espère ??
Ha bah si ! Je viens d'attraper un Roucoul
niveau 4,
t'es marrant toi !
Ho ! Un Chenipan ! C'est mon jour de chance aujourd'hui !
Alors je le reconnais, il y a des éditeurs qui font des efforts
ça...
Mais c'était franchement pas la peine.
La jauge de vie par exemple.
Bon bah. Dans pas mal de jeu il y en a plus.
Comme dans...
Call of Duty ou Gears of War ...
Maintenant tu te prends une balle ça va pas bien ...
Et puis t'attends un peu et ça va mieux !
Comme dans la vraie vie quoi ...
Ahhh ...
Mon épaule !!! Je vais mourir !
Oh non !!
Ah ! ça va mieux !
Qui pour un Monopoly ?
Je fais la banque !
C'est vrai que c'est beaucoup mieux !
Alors dans les nouveaux jeux ...
Il y a un autre truc qui est pas mal
dans " Skyrim " hein ... 150 heures de jeu,
des graphismes éblouissants etc...
Quand un ennemi s’approche, la musique change.
Paye ton suspense !
C'est pas la peine de m'attaquer je sais que t'es là !
Qu'es ce que j'ai dit ?!
Enfin bon, c'est pas ça le vrai problème
dans les jeux vidéos
hein parce que ...
Moi le truc qui m’énerve le plus
sur Terre !
Encore plus que
Dragon Ball Evolution,
mon voisin qui fait des travaux,
Cortex,
Les chapeaux de shérif ...
Bref le truc qui me donne envie de tout casser
c'est quand je suis entre deux mecs qui discutent d'un jeu que je connais pas !
Avec Diabl0x9 j'ai fait une quad en RD au spot de la map Seatown
Perso je suis encore sur MW2 et mon seul clip c'est une triple au spot Highrise
Pfff ... La derniere chose que les snip' arrivent encore a faire dans le jeu
c'est jouer machine de guerre plus LG pour tenter des tempershot sur le dernier mec vivant quoi !
Le pire c'est les mecs qui font du setup pour leurs FM quoi ...
Allô n'importe quoi !
Alors géneralement je leur sors mon UMP 45 et je leur mets des bons gros Dropshot
en les rushant plein middle ils adorent ça.
Quand c'est comme ça ...
J'ai juste envie de faire une seule chose :
Et la je suis AFK toute l'aprem
Et sinon c'est quand la dernière fois que vous avez eu une copine ?!
Hein ?!
Non dans les Sims ça compte pas !
Ah...
Ah au fait tu peux rejoindre ma page FaceBook !
Et voir toute mes autres videos sur Cyprien ...
.fr.
A bientôt !